we know a lot of 20 year olds or maybe
even a little bit older who want to make
movies but they haven't is it ever a
struggle for you do you ever feel like
you have so many ideas but for some
reason you feel like your hands are tied
or you don't feel like that I think that
in recent years I don't feel like my
hands are tied as much because now I can
point to work that I've done and I think
that's true if you're 20 40 or 80 it
doesn't really matter how old you are if
you've decided you want to start making
films but what does matter is that you
can point to your body of work whether
it's good or not as a whole nother topic
and I'll leave that for other people to
debate but if there are things that I've
done that people have enjoyed then I'm
more likely to have the leverage and
capacity to make other things that
hopefully other people will also enjoy
and so for me and my earlier years it
was a little bit harder because I had to
fight for credibility and that's because
of age I'm not saying that is
necessarily unfounded but perhaps
sometimes unfair because when you're 20
years old and you want to run off and go
make a film why does a 40 or 50 year old
financier need to trust you over the 35
or 40 year old that has years of
experience that the adult in the room
that can command more presence and so
for me starting so young as a filmmaker
really allowed me to hone my
communication skills also honed my
ability to talk to people in different
ways so that they would understand and
hopefully appreciate that I would be
credible and that they could trust me
with their money and their respect that
I wouldn't do something that would
dissuade them from following through
because I would follow through with my
own work and so I think the answer is
really it's how you present yourself and
how well you know what you're talking
about don't oversell or over promise
things you can under deliver
do that is there a point though where
you can you can undersell yourself oh
absolutely but I at would argue that's
may be better to undersell yourself at
the initial onset because if you can do
things that people don't know you can do
or don't think you can do you surprise
them and when you can surprise them then
you have the capacity to make people
excited about what you're doing and so I
think sometimes underselling is perhaps
more valuable than telling them
everything or overselling is that due to
expectation let's suppose you tell them
oh yeah and you embellish what you can
do and then you somehow fall short but
if you under sell yourself and then
that's like this sort of unplanned
surprise to them absolutely and I think
that in general people like unplanned
surprises they like to see things as a
surprise I mean it's even using the
example of going to a theater and seeing
a film and the ? instead of the period
if you're always asking yourself what's
going to happen next what's going to
happen next if we're not telling you
what to think in a film I think it's the
same thing for production and the same
thing for development if you're
constantly showing the people you work
with that you have something unexpected
within you then they can get excited
about your vision and what you want to
do because they know that this person
has something within them that will
constantly surprise and I think that if
you can find that then you can find
success
you